Now,
let me,
let me pose this to you.
So I know a guy,
he's a treasure hunter by trade.
Very cool old guy.
Australian guy,
lived in Perth and uh,
for years he's like,
I know where this certain Spanish ship went down.
Long story short,
he finds it right,
digs up one single gold coin and he's like,
it's here.
I know it's here.
It's big spear fishermen.
Adventure guy goes,
spends tens of thousand of dollars is not a rich man,
spends tens of thousand dollars,
got gets all this excavator equipment,
goes to this very remote area of Northwestern Australia,
pulls up something like $10 million worth of treasure,
takes it home legally,
declares it all.
Tells,
tells the government gets all compensated.
They give him three or four pieces.
You can see his treasure in the museum in Perth.
Here's this guy who would've retired,
been a wealthy man,
you know,
had his whole life taken care of because of this thing he was obsessed with and
then found and then got the tools on his own dime to go and get it declared it
has a confiscated to food.
Well,
that's where,
because you find stuff in the ocean and they take it and people become
billionaires.
Right.
They find Russian or a Roman chair ships filled with gold coins.
Yeah.
But for whatever reason,
like this was considered like a history historically valuable.
So it was taken for the museum.
Right.
And he got,
yeah,
a few coins and no money.
I,
I gotta look up the guy's name.
I know a similar story.
It's happened in America.
Okay.
Uh,
the guy that went to hunt it got investors.
Right.
And when he got the gold,
he just kept it.
When investors ask for the money,
he shorted said,
I don't know what you're talking about.
I lost it.
Or I don't know where I put it or I don't know where it is.
So He's,
I think he's currently in jail under contempt of court.
Oh Geez.
Being asked where is it?
And he said,
I don't know.
He's taking a lot of detector tests.
It people think because kids have it or something like that,
but they have no idea where it is.
It's a crazy story.
Well,
that's a weird one too,
because like what are you going to do with it?
Right?
Like if people are staring at you,
they're,
they're like constantly,
look,
where is it?
Where is it?
You're like,
I don't have it.
They're going to keep looking like how much is it worth?
Millions.
I think each coin might be worth a million and you might have something like 20
to 30 of them.
It's like a lot of money.
It's insane.
Well,
you got to bring it to someone who's going to give you a piece.
You know?
You got to bring it to someone,
but then you're going to get caught.
Where'd you get the 5 million bend?
What exactly the dental found it.
Yeah.
What do you do?
Well,
it's interesting when things are historical,
right?
You don't know like who,
who does it belong to?
A museum.
Does it belong to the person who finds it?
Right?
Like what are the,
what are the rules and are we making these rules up as we go along?
It's,
yeah,
it's worth 20 million.
There's,
I'd found a story is still in jail right now.
Wow.
Jailed.
Treasure Hunter ordered to pay nearly 20 million.
This is Tommy Thompson.
Tommy Thompson's on it.
Yeah.
That sounds like the kind of guy.